So last week we talked about the need for love when we're engaging in conversation
and we want to get out, we want to be loving toward other people.
But if you or any of your students are all like me, that very
concept is terrifying.
The fact that I have to go out, not the love part, that's not so terrifying, but the
part where you go out and actually have a conversation is terrifying.
I need a plan of attack.
Some of your students, I'm sure, are very introverted, very reserved,
and I'm not all that good at the small talk of just sort of having a conversation.
In fact, I actively try to avoid small talk.
I like to get to the point. So when I'm entering a conversation about spiritual
things or I want to advance a conversation and get to the gospel so I can get to
Jesus because I want them to know who Jesus is, I need a plan of attack.
But I'm sure many of your students, maybe yourself, because I know I get there all
the time, is what happens when they ask you a question that you can't answer?
Because what happens is we get into these moments where we say, somebody asks us a
question, we immediately want to have an answer to come right back and be like,
yeah, I've got that answer and I've got that answer.
Because we feel like if we have all of the answers, then we can somehow convince the
other person that what we believe is absolutely right because we've got all the
answers to all their questions. Well, nothing could be further from the truth.
That's not at all the case. And there are going to be times when we get stumped and
we don't know what to say or the person that we're talking to has a belief system or
a view on things that we're just not all that familiar with.
You can't know everything about every single person.
But there's a really simple strategy that I want you to sort of add in
to talk with your students about, is when they're engaged in a conversation,
you want to make sure that you are asking questions.
And that's what this week is all about, the idea and the art of asking questions.
Questions are so, so important. See, if we ask good questions,
then we're going to get probably good answers.
And just like any good teacher knows, you don't ask yes or no questions.
You ask sort of in-depth, sort of probing questions, why kinds of questions to
draw out of people the answers that you want or that you need.
Well, the same goes true with our conversations.
But this especially works if you have no idea what the other person is talking
about. Because you can probe a little bit deeper and get them to talk through.
At the same time, you're giving off the idea because you are
and you want to be extremely interested in what they have to say.
And that goes back to last week when we talked about love and building relationships
and that sort of thing. So there are two specific questions that we can ask somebody
if you get stumped. Okay, so the first question is simple.
What do you mean?
By that so
this question is used when you're really not sure what all the person
thinks person says something that you're just not all that clear on um I believe
that Jesus is just a good moral teacher well what do you mean by that like you can
probably guess what they might mean but maybe that's not what all the God just you
know doesn't exist because there's too much evil in the world well what do you mean
by that and if you're you can what do you mean by that people to death it's just you
can go over and over and over again what do you mean by that or some variation of it
but it's a very simple question it does two things one it digs deeper into the
person what they're actually thinking but also buys you time to think about what you
want to say a little bit so it allows them to clarify what they're saying so they
can't just make a one-off statement to you, but it also buys you a little bit of
time to think through their opinion more thoroughly and more thoughtfully.
The second question is, how do you come to that conclusion?
Or did you come?
Again, people make one-off statements all the time.
How'd they get there? So if they, again, they said something like, you know, God
can't exist because there's too much evil in the world.
Well how do you come to that conclusion there's a much larger explanation that I
need for that and you don't have to you don't say it with kind of an attitude but
you say it very like I'm interested like how did you come to that conclusion I
really want to know I'm really interested in what you have to say what this does is
this is helps them see that you are actually interested in what they have to say
that you actually want to know what they think rather than just give them
what you think. And there's a big difference between the two.
And again, that's why last week and this week are connected together.
Because by doing this kind of thing, you're showing them love.
You're showing them relationships.
You're showing them that you care about them as a person.
Not just feeding them your opinion.
The most valuable tool that you or your students have is the
ability to sit down face-to-face with somebody to have a conversation.
There's a lot of tips and tricks to sharing your faith, but the number one thing to
keep in your toolbox is the ability to ask great questions and engage in deep,
meaningful conversations with another person.
It does so much more than just give the gospel.
It builds relationships so that I'll say when that person finally receives
Christ, that discipleship can actually begin rather
than just a conversion.